[Music]
on a more serious note the truth story
Sid had been doing the show of shows 50
51 51 52 full seasons 39 hour and a half
shows a year right and it occurred to me
that we were being recorded on
cellophane I don't know what the hell we
were it was like we were recorded on
saran wrap I mean nothing I said you
know you go to the movies you see Danny
Kaye you see him forever there's Harold
Lloyd there's Charlie Chaplin Laurel and
Hardy they're on celluloid and they'll
be around forever I said I you know
you're a legitimate comic genius and no
one will ever remember what the hell you
did unless unless seriously unless we go
let's make movies like you want him to
go out to LA and be like a hole somebody
at Columbia Pictures and I had arranged
for us to and I said quit just you know
you've done two years you've got another
two-year contract coming up just tell
them thank you it's been wonderful and
and just to have the guts and you know
quit let's go to Hollywood and make
movies and be remembered and have your
stuff literally immortalized you know be
be on the big screen forever and he said
yes you're right and he was getting
about $5,000 a week in those days that
was like a fortune and after two days I
didn't hear from him and I said Sidney I
called him Sidney I said what about
Hollywood Columbia Pictures but you know
let's go he said I can't do it
they offered me $25,000 a show and I
couldn't so he said I'll do it after the
show is over and unfortunately he was so
good to show around for ten years and by
then you know the ship had sailed
so he really I mean I've never no-one's
put more of their bone marrow into
television and Sid Caesar and by the end
of that run he had he was exhausted
exactly he'd given everything that he
possibly could and but you know and I I
went on to make movies and he said I
told you
you went from me to Hitler yeah yeah you
went you went on any bet you always used
to tell him I wouldn't be anywhere I
said no Sid Caesar no Mel Brooks and I I
meant it I said see you seriously meant
it